[موسيقى]
حسنًا، نحن نتابع مأساة مميتة
في البحر تتعلق بالمهاجرين، يقول الصليب الأحمر إن
41 شخصًا بينهم العديد من
الأطفال لقوا حتفهم في غرق سفينة بالقرب من
جزيرة لامبيدوزا الإيطالية،
وتحدث الصليب الأحمر إلى الناجين الأربعة من السفينة
الذين قالوا إن القارب غرق في غضون ساعة  عند
مغادرة تونس بعد أن ضربتها
موجة كبيرة منذ عدة أيام،
تم إنقاذ جميع الناجين بواسطة
سفينة خاصة. يمثل هذا الحادث الأحدث في
سلسلة من المآسي التي تحدث بالقرب من
لامبيدوزا، وهي وجهة رئيسية
للمهاجرين الذين يسعون إلى دخول دول الاتحاد الأوروبي
أو للمزيد  هذا دعونا نحضر
بن ويدمان من CNN الموجود اليوم في روما، بن،
ماذا نعرف عن أولئك الذين
فقدوا حياتهم وماذا
تقول السلطات أيضًا عما حدث،
حسنًا، لا نعرف بالضبط عدد
الأشخاص المفقودين والمفترض أنهم ماتوا الآن
هذا  لأن هؤلاء الناجين الأربعة يقولون
إنهم يعتقدون أنه كان هناك 45
شخصًا على متن هذه السفينة عندما غادرت
أه هذا القارب في الواقع عندما غادر
ميناء فوكس التونسي أه أواخر الأسبوع الماضي
الآن لم ترد أي تقارير عن
انتشال أي جثث  من البحر،
لذلك هذا رقم تقريبي أه في
هذه المرحلة وتذكر أيضًا أن
هؤلاء الأشخاص، هؤلاء الناجون الأربعة
يقال إنهم ثلاثة رجال وامرأة
ربما تعرضوا لصدمة نفسية إلى حد ما بعد هذه
التجربة وهم الآن في
جزيرة لامبيدوزا الإيطالية وهي عبارة عن
نوع رئيسي من نقاط التجمع للمهاجرين
واللاجئين الذين يتم إنقاذهم في البحر في تلك
المنطقة من البحر الأبيض المتوسط، ضع في اعتبارك
بالطبع أن لامبيدوزا، هذه
الجزيرة الإيطالية هي في الواقع أقرب إلى تونس
منها إلى البر الرئيسي الإيطالي
والآن من الواضح أن السلطات أصبحت هذه نقطة تجمع رئيسية
الوضع مستمر بالتأكيد خاصة
في فصل الصيف عندما تكون المياه
أكثر هدوءًا إلى حد ما في البحر الأبيض المتوسط
هذا عندما أه الناس يميلون إلى محاولة
القيام بهذا العبور الخطير للغاية الآن في
هذه المرحلة أه الأرقام تشير
إلى أننا نتجه نحو عدد قياسي من
المهاجرين  واللاجئون الذين يصلون إلى إيطاليا
حتى الآن هذا العام اعتبارًا من اليوم 9
أغسطس وصل ما يقرب من 94000 شخص إلى
شواطئ إيطاليا وهو ضعف
العدد من العام الماضي في هذا الوقت من
العام وثلاثة أضعاف هذا العدد
أه من العام  قبل
طريق بيكي في هذه المرحلة، هناك الكثير ممن
يبحثون عما غالبًا ما يكون طريقًا مميتًا،
حسنًا، أعني أنه عليك حقًا أن تنظر إلى
الصورة الكبيرة وأن هؤلاء الأشخاص
يأتون من جميع أنواع الأماكن، فهم
يأتون من أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء الكبرى  من
الشرق الأوسط على سبيل المثال، نرى
أن ثالث أكبر عدد من
المهاجرين الذين يدخلون إيطاليا هذا العام يأتي
من مصر. من الواضح أن مصر هي دولة
تعاني من
أزمة اقتصادية عميقة يأتي الناس منها من أماكن
بعيدة مثل بنجلاديش وباكستان.  ما
نراه هو أن هناك
العديد من الأزمات في كل
هذه الأماكن، سواء كانت الحرب، أو
اليأس الاقتصادي، أو الفساد، أو عدم الاستقرار، مما
أدى أساسًا إلى إقناع هؤلاء الناس
بأن الأمر يستحق المخاطرة بالموت في
البحر الأبيض المتوسط، وحتى الآن هذا العام أكثر
من 2000 شخص.  يقال إن هناك أشخاصًا لقوا حتفهم،
وبالطبع ربما يكون هذا
تقديرًا منخفضًا أثناء محاولتهم عبور
البحر الأبيض المتوسط، لكن من الواضح أن هذه المخاطرة
تستحق العناء في رأي بعض
العديد من هؤلاء الأشخاص، كل هؤلاء الأشخاص
أكثر من الموت في حرب في
الشرق الأوسط.  شرق أفريقيا أو جنوب الصحراء الكبرى أو
أي مكان آخر، هذه هي المشكلة التي
نركز عليها على المهاجرين ومغادرة تونس أو
ليبيا أو غيرهما، ولكن من الواضح أن
المشاكل الجذرية الأساسية الحقيقية
أكبر بكثير ولم يتم معالجتها
بيكي نعم